I thought you'd be interested in this
apparently Martin Scorsese said
something oh not this guy again he said
Marvel isn't cinema right yes so he also
said uh some movies are bad oh the
pretentious overrated also said just
because a movie makes a lot of money
doesn't mean it's good that just flat
out doesn't make sense like even on a
grammatical level he also said and I
don't know what the context is here uh
this is Cinema not the meme sorry dude
no one wants to watch your four hour
black and white Eastern European movie
about a depressed clown who can't pay a
mortgage because he doesn't have a
mortgage he lives in a clown car
jeez you don't know who Martin Scorsese
is do you he made Avatar no